I think you're going to someday soon
probably very soon
realize you're wasting your time
it's time to love yourself and just
be a little more responsible it's your
life
you got to get fed up with this kind of
life you're living
yes or no
but I'm definitely sick of wasting
wasting everything that I've been
granted you know what I mean yeah you've
been granted a lot I'm very grateful for
it and I'm ready to return
the Gratitude and
the emblem of
complete retribution
so much to make up for
foreign
loving ourselves comes from
the
esteem building things that we do in our
lives
and you you haven't done a whole lot of
that you're getting a lot of love from
people that see you you know know you
through these videos and that's I'm sure
feels good but that's not going to solve
your problem
you need to feel like you deserve it
sure
and you're not going to feel like you
deserve it if you're just screwing
around on the streets
wasting your life
there's so much more
that I'm
prepared for preparing for
I'm just fed up with denying
what
how do I Define that
denying myself I suppose or denying
the universe that
embodies around me
the kind of experience that
that really is
Beyond warranted I suppose uh
Beyond necessary
Beyond vindictive
[Music]
what emotions do you feel sometimes when
you're by yourself and are you angry are
you an angry person
yes or no I suppose I'm angry at
there's so much indecessity in this life
you know what I mean
such that shouldn't be happening
so much that needs to be happening
so much that isn't isn't
it
I would say honestly
it takes losing everything to truly
remind you
what's worth it
you know
and for what it's worth
come help
on high water
I so passionately
want to express
the sort of love that
like isn't there you know what I mean
like
sort of expression of
a complete evolution of
Beyond karmic Integrity I don't know
kind of the waste
I think you're just maturing you're just
growing up
this is what it looks like for some
people
Define
you know a lot of us when we were in our
early 20s were
belligerent stubborn hard-headed defiant
and eventually as you
your rough edges get rounded out from
being knocked around by life
I wouldn't say it's conforming but you
you just become a little more
in line with how the world works
that's not how the world works
I'm sorry
okay
that's not how the world works
it's not the sort of world that
foreign
what's coming
I think
there's a big world out there
hitch
foreign
what kind of things do you think you
might be ready for
definitely ready to transition to
it's not just about being more myself
but I'm definitely ready for my
transition
I think that's the perfect uh
perfect Patriots
and just throw yourself at life and then
you surprised that you have back at us
be surprised what
I don't say what you truly deserve but
you know
I made enough mistakes to know
to know how to fix things
I think you're intelligent enough and
creative enough and clever enough to do
anything you want to do
that's true no fans but there's
something part of me that's holding me
back
I don't know if it's my dysmorphia with
my body or just how I
I always knew that this sort of moment
would come
a day like this
it's a perfect day for it perfect
conversation I'd say
where I can just
make up for last time my house
you're only 26.
you missed your birthday Lauren and I
went looking for you in West Hollywood
on your birthday we couldn't find you I
did miss my birthday I was
I don't know if I wanted to
kill myself or dire
I don't know what the was wrong
with me
I was all alone I was so miserable
I have no clue why
I told you to meet me at my studio
downtown
I'll take you to West Hollywood
you would have had fun
doesn't mean I can't know but you're
right
it's like I'm torn sort of there's a
part of me that
let's say wishes I were better off Dad
but
you wouldn't be better off dead
I think I say this about you a lot I
think there's a fine line between genius
and crazy
yeah
and you go back and forth all the time
foreign
like I'm
like and be real as you know what I
mean
and then sometimes it's like
the cause of the logo but you know
I need to start over
in a sense
plenty of people start over at much
older ages than you
no I mean I'm sort of ready for my uh
looks more than a comeback
sorry just caught me on uh
so every day that can go from bad to fun
toxic and
just like that
foreign
do you feel like you're wasting time
in a sense yes in a sense no
it just made me more focused on
what needs to be done
I've definitely
I've wasted enough time to know that
I can reclaim it
in a sense
reclaim lost posh
do you feel like I'm wasting your time
well I mean you're 26.
a lot of people in their 20s waste a lot
of time
this is the 20s or 40 just you're
figuring yourself out
I don't even like this isn't
I want to say this isn't me but this is
not
I don't know
I know I'm so much more passionate life
in me I got some
definitely have a lot to make up for I'd
say
but I'm very grateful for every little
thing for everything
it's good to have it's good to have
regrets sometimes
it motivates you
definitely it's not regret it's um to
change
to revise I guess
because you you have plenty of talent
you're very creative all that you have
there's no question about that but if
you're not motivated that Talent gets
wasted
I have it in me
and I do have the motivation I'm just
like where's that all feeling
sorry for myself or I know being
expected to feel
Beyond apologetic
you think talking any of this stuff out
with a therapist would be helpful
I don't need therapy I need life I need
excitement and intensity and
what I really really want
is
validity I don't know
a lot of people out there think they
know what it's about you know what I
mean but
nothing practice makes perfect
unproced us
from malice to Alice or from Alice
tamales
you're figuring it out
I know what it's about
but
it feels like someone's missing
feels like someone's missing